more than six hundred thousand
operations and appointments have been
canceled by the UK's Health Service
since the start of the Year all due to
Industrial Action overpay Now England's
most senior doctors are on the picket
line causing the worst disruption to
hospitals since the 1970s this is a
marketing trained doctors I can double
my salary by moving across to Ireland I
can double my salary moving to Australia
and if the agencies chasing Consultants
on a daily basis this government is
going to Hemorrhage doctors
the National Health Service is
celebrating 75 years of providing Health
Care free at the point of use but it's
in crisis under staffed starved of
investment and dealing with an aging
population we have listened to the
independent pay review body
recommendations and it's now time to put
patience first and for Consultants to
call off this strike and to focus on
patients the government has offered
senior doctors a six percent pay rise
but that's been rejected by their Union
as it doesn't even cover inflation which
is at eight percent I think they should
have got else 10 10 percent
10 percent is reasonable I mean I know
our doctors they work very very hard
they do deserved and as much as they
used to earn I think the sort of the
inflation cost of living crisis that has
massively decreased sort of the value of
the actual money so I think it's fair
it's fair to say that around two-thirds
of the public according to polling have
supported previous strikes by more
Junior NHS staff
these strikes are piling on the pressure
on an already unpopular conservative
government last year prime minister
Rishi sunak promised to cut waiting
times for consultations and operations
but there are now 7.4 million people on
NHS waiting lists a record and more will
be added with three more days of strikes
scheduled
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Central London